if you've ever looked at a flight
tracker sometime around 10:00 or 11:00
p.m. Eastern you might have noticed
something perfect lines of planes
stretching all the way to Europe these
are just some of the over 2000 daily
flights that cross the northern Atlantic
with so many flights there just has to
be organization this is the most direct
route from New York to London you may
think it's this a straight line but that
straight line isn't actually a straight
line this curved line is a straight line
because despite what some may think the
earth is curved from New York to London
the curve you see on a flat map isn't
too extreme but in the case of a longer
flight such as from New York to Bangkok
the most direct route is not this but
this straight over the North Pole it
makes a lot more sense if you look at a
North Pole oriented map if you draw the
most direct route between Atlanta and
London you'll see that it passes over
every major East Coast International
Airport that means that planes from
Atlanta to Europe travel on the exact
same route as planes from Charlotte
Washington Baltimore Philadelphia New
York and Boston all these transatlantic
planes typically leave between 6 & 8
p.m. Eastern to time their arrival for
early morning in Europe that means that
there are potentially hundreds of planes
all going the exact same route at the
exact same time the North Atlantic also
has something known as the jet stream
these easterly winds average around 110
miles per hour and if planes fly in them
they can cut hours off their travel time
however the winds are only strongest in
a line three miles high and 100 miles
wide that further concentrates the
flights on average an eastbound
transatlantic flight from New York to
London takes about six hours and 15
minutes coming back against the jet
stream the same flight takes over seven
hours sometimes the winds can be even
more active such as on January 8th 2015
when British Airways flight 114 flew
from New York to London in only five
hours and 16 minutes a new record for a
commercial subsonic plane on that day
the jet stream was blowing over 200
miles per hour and the Boeing triple7
reached a speed of 745 miles per hour
only 16 miles per hour below the sound
barrier so when winds can cut an hour
off a flight and a triple seven burns
2,700 gallons of fuel per hour and jet
fuel costs a dollar in 89 cents per
gallon
that's a 5103 dollar difference
between being in the right and the wrong
wins hopefully you now see why this is
important so there are all these planes
that are flying the exact same route but
usually that's no problem the busiest
route in North America New York to
Chicago sees over 100 flights per day
leaving as frequently as every five
minutes during the morning and evening
rush and these planes just fly the most
efficient route before the flight route
planners file a plan with air traffic
control and during the flight
they're just directed by air traffic
control in a way that keeps some five
nautical miles from other planes the
difference between New York to Chicago
and New York to London is that over the
North Atlantic
there is no radar you see radar only
extends about 250 miles offshore
transatlantic planes can be more than a
thousand miles from shore that's why
every morning the route planner is at
Gander air traffic control center in
gander Newfoundland published today's
North Atlantic tracks the night before
every airline that will fly across the
Atlantic the following day sends Gander
a preferred route message indicating
what they think the best route will be
for the most part Gander Center follows
these requests and creates a set of ten
or so routes these tracks attempt to get
the most amount of planes on the most
efficient route to Europe the tracks are
labeled Zulu being the southernmost
route Yankee being the second
southernmost then x-ray than whiskey and
so on and so forth here's how a flight
on the tracks works and I'll warn you
this is when the video gets technical
let's say we're going from New York to
Paris around half an hour before
scheduled departure the captain talks to
normal air traffic control to request
clearance for the route up to around
Newfoundland Canada in most cases
clearance is given and soon after will
take off about when the plane crosses
the Gulf of st. Lawrence the pilot will
request the North Atlantic track that he
or she desires
here's today's message describing the
day's routes over the Atlantic after
looking over this the pilot decides to
request track whiskey that means that at
least for now we'll head towards the
Raffin waypoint our oceanic entry point
waypoints are fixed spots that are used
for flight navigation these are much
easier for air traffic control to
communicate to pilots than map
coordinates when speaking over radio
occasionally you'll see some creatively
named waypoints just north of Lebanon
New Hampshire there's ham burger and
fries on approach to Kansas City Airport
there's spicy barbeque turkey smoked
ribs Boston has two waypoints in support
of their sports teams but
Cubs and bears some Waypoint names are
more somber on the northern approach
route to Washington Reagan National
Airport just miles away from where a
plane hit the Pentagon on 9/11 the
waypoints read we will never forget
September 11th since the North Atlantic
tracks change every day
the modem just gives the entry and exit
way points and then coordinates for the
rabbin between since the track
coordinates are pre-programmed into the
autopilot before takeoff there's no
reason to name them as waypoints since
they won't be given over radio in the
case of this flight we're requesting
track whiskey and more than likely
Gander Control Center will give us
permission although sometimes they'll
tell us to take a different track
usually because we're closer to another
plane than the minimum separation
distance since it's much more difficult
to know where planes are over the North
Atlantic they're required to be 15
minutes separated about 140 miles rather
than the normal 5 miles in areas with
radar coverage assuming we're granted
clearance we'll head towards the RAF and
Waypoint and make sure that our
satellite communication systems are
working then we'll check to see if our
high-frequency radio is working a backup
in case other communications go down
minutes later just after passing RAF and
Waypoint the controller will say radar
services terminated have a good night
and we're on our own
all the North Atlantic tracks are
pre-loaded onto autopilot so there's
really nothing to do except wait when we
hit 30 degrees west will enter the
shanwick airspace approaching Western
Europe we switch our radios to shanwick
frequency and fly a few more hours to
our oceanic exit point guns away point
meaning we've successfully traversed the
northern Atlantic I hope you enjoyed
this went over productions video make
sure to check out my last video on guam
here please also subscribe to this
channel by clicking here if you're
already subscribed and not following me
on Twitter congratulations you're in the
98.7%
but help me make that percentage smaller
by going and following me on Twitter at
1-over Pro there's also a fan moderated
subreddit for this channel which you can
find at wwe.com slash are slash win over
productions thanks again for watching
and I'll see you soon for another win
over productions video